bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public on est
ensemble pour 90 minutes de débat et de
reportage pour donner du sens à
l'actualité aux crises aux conflits que
nous traversons et c'est une émission
spéciale que nous vous proposons ce soir
consacré à la guerre au Proche Orient
avec cette information importante un
accord pour un gouvernement d'urgence a
été trouvé en Israël pour la durée de la
guerre en parallèle les bombardements de
Gaza s'intensifi plus de 2300 sans cible
touché depuis samedi selon des sources
officielles l'État hébreu peut-il
éradiquer le Hamas comme l'a promis
Benjamin netaniaahou que provoque
l'horreur des massacres dans plusieurs
kibuts au sein de la société israélienne
mais aussi dans la communauté
internationale quel pays pourrait jouer
à terme peut-être dans longtemps un rôle
de médiateur on répond à à toutes ces
questions dans un instant et puis dans
la seconde partie de l'émission C'est un
zoom sur le Hamas que je vous propose
voici comment son chef Ismaïl aner
justifie les attaqu de
samedi trop c'est trop le cycle des
intifad et des révolution dans la lutte
pour la libération de notre terre et de
nos prisonniers qui croupiss dans les
prisons de l'occupation doit
s'achev organisation financement
soutiens étrangers adhésion des
Palestiniens on va décortiquer le
fonctionnement et la stratégie du Hamas
avec expert dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
le récit de cette 5e journée de guerre
Israël affiche l'Union nationale redam
ravit c'est d'abord d'un point de vue
politique que la situation a changé en
fin d'après-midi Benjamin netaniaou a
annoncé la constitution d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale avec la
création d'un cabinet de guerre sur le
terrain les combats se
poursuit des explosions et d'épaisses
fumée blanche aperçu dans le ciel de
Gaza tout au long de cette journée
larost israélienne se matérialise par de
nombreux raides
aériens depuis Gaza le Hamas organise
des contreattaque envoyant des roquettes
provoquant d'importants dégâts comme ici
dans la ville
d'achderot alors que les buldoers rasent
les structures détruites les habitants
vengance le Hamas n'est pas une armée ce
sont des terroristes et il faut traiter
la terreur de la même manière il faut
riposté de la même
manière d'autres mouvements étrangers
sisent dans ce conflit à l'image du
Hezbollah libanais qui organise des
frappe vers Israël des chefs d'État
s'enprennent à l'État hébreux comme le
président turc
perdoan ces attaques disproportionné
contre Gaza sans aucun fondement moral
pourrait placer Israël dans une position
inattendue et indésir
une autre partie de la communauté
internationale plaide pour l'apaisement
à l'image de ce message du pape
François Le MoyenOrient n'a pas besoin
de guerre mais de paix une paix fondée
sur la justice le dialogue et le courage
de la
fraternité même tonalité du côté du
gouvernement français réuni en conseil
des ministres ce matin la franceent
éalement du côté du droit international
et de la paix don l' et restera un
artisan convaincu tout doit être fait
pour permettre d'éviter la situation
d'escalade au Moyen-Orient protéger les
civils éviter l'embrasement du
Moyen-Orient des appels à la paix qui ne
trouvent pas encore d'écho car pour
l'instant c'est la guerre qui fait
rage j'accueille mes invités Laurent Sam
bonsoir vous êtes ancienne
correspondante en Israël et aux
États-Unis Aurélien deniso bonsoir et
bienvenue professeur de géopolitique à
l'Institut libre des relations
international et des Sciences Politiques
de Lyon et puis à l'Institut catholique
de Paris et vous êtes spécialiste du
Moyen-Orient Guillaume Ansel bonsoirons
bienvenue à vous ancien officier
écrivain français auteur de ce blog ne
pas subir j'accueille également Mathieu
croissant d'au éditorialiste politique
bonsoir Mathieu bienvenue à vous euh
beaucoup d'informations en cette fin
d'après-midi je commence quand même par
celles qui sont confirmé d'abord ce
gouvernement d'urgence pour la durée de
la guerre Laurence Saim euh Benjamin
netanahou a sacrifié entre guillemets
ses ses ministres d'extrême et
ultraorthodoxe pour réunir autour de lui
benigand et d'autres ouais vu l'émotion
du pays il en avait besoin parce qu'il
était dans une crise politique
importante et il y a un désir de la part
de Benjamin netanahou de montrer l'unité
nationale j'insiste sur l'importance de
benig Gand parce que benigons au moment
de la guerre de Gaza en 2014 était le
chef de l'armée israélienne donc il
connaît très bien la situation à Gaza
lorsqu'il y a eu en 2014 une offensive
terrestre et ensuite il a été au sein
d'un gouvernement israélien de 2020 à
2022 le ministre des Armées donc c'est
quelqu'un qui va servir d'une certaine
manière au mieux Benjamin netaniaahou de
par sa connaissance du terrain de Gaza
et d'autre part et bien c'est ce
gouvernement d'unité nationale qui est
indispensable tant la crise évidemment
est sérieuse en Israël et et les mots
sont importants le temps de la guerre on
imagine et on aura l'occasion d'en
parler forcément sur ce plateau qui aura
ensuite des conséquences politiques et
d'autres élections peut-être en tout cas
pour Benjamin netaniaahou le un cabinet
de guerre Guillaume hsel ça veut dire
qu'on est pour encore longtemps dans le
temps de la guerre c'est une évidence de
dire ça mais il faut le rappeler ouis
c'est quand même extrêmement surprenant
parce que finalement les premiers mots
de Benjamin netanahou justement ça a été
de dire on est en guerre et on va
remporter cette guerre et alors c'est là
où j'ai du mal à suivre je suis un
ancien officier je vois pas comment on
gagne ce type de guerre contre le Hamas
parce qu'il y a une confusion totale qui
est largement étendue dans les esprits
entre on a l'impression que la bande de
Gaza où sont réfugiés 2 millions de
Palestiniens c'est le Hamas le Hamas
n'est pas la bande de Gaza donc faire la
guerre à la bande de Gaza pour mettre
fin au Hamas c'est un nonsens d'un point
de vue militaire les frappes auxqueles
j'assiste vous l'avez rappelé plus de
2000 cibles touchées ce sont
essentiellement c'est une source
gouvernementale israélienne qui des
moyens euh de bombardement aérien et de
bombardement terrestre j'ai guidé
pendant des années ce genre de
bombardement pardon mais avec ça dans
une zone comme Gaza vous ne faites que
des dommages collatéraux pour tuer une
personne vous en tuez 50 donc pour moi
cette guerre elle va surtout légitimer
le Hamas pour les 10 prochaines années
c'est une impasse sanglante dans
laquelle s'est lancé netaniaahou pour sa
propre survie politiqueou oui mais
aélien Denizo on peut quand même
rappeler que Israël a été agressé et a
donc le droit de riposter bah tout
dépend évidemment du narratif qu'on va
adopter c'est-à-dire que on entre dans
cette vieille cerelle qui a commencé
vous écoutez le camp palestinien on vous
dira que eux-mêmes se défendent vous
écoutez le camp israélien c'est
évidemment de la légitime défense si on
continue dans ce cycle ça fait quand
même 10 15 20 ans qu'on a ce cycle en
fait des attentats des tir de roquette
des bombardements pour le moment on n'
pas obtenu de solution estce j'entends
votre discours et sur ce plateau on
essaie toujours de de prendre du recul
mais est-ce que ce discours est audible
quand on a en en tête les images des
massacres de ce qui s'est passé
notamment dans les dans les kibuts de de
ces on va pas donner de chiffrre parce
qu'on ne les connaît pas précisément
mais de ces enfants qui ont été tués ces
bébés qui ont été tués le cre nous a
horrifié les images nous ont horrifié il
faut prendre garde à un élément tout de
même qui est que aujourd'hui sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment on a de tout
qui circule et on a en particulier des
vidéos qui vont circuler chez nous
tandis que par exemple dans le monde
arabe on va avoir d'autres types de
vidéos qui vont circuler par exemple des
bombardements qui vont créer un narratif
complètement différent les algorithmes
font qu'en plus on va généralement avoir
de plus en plus d'éléments qui vont dans
le sens de ce qu'on regarde le risque
serait de créer une fracture
irrémédiable justement avec par exemple
deux narratifs complètement différents
sur le même événement ENF au-delà du
narratif il y a quand même eu des fait
samedi il a eu un nombre de morts don on
ne connaî pas exactement encore
l'ampleur mais extrêmement conséquent
que que Benjamin netanahou ne peut pas
non plus rester sans rien faire c'est
pas juste une histoire de narratif c'est
qu'il est obligé de montrer qu'il fait
quelque chose précisément ce que ve mais
est-ce que faire quelque chose en tout
cas est-ce que le faire avec la méthode
militaire justement est-ce que ce serait
la réponse qui serait efficace ça
pourrait calmer l'opinion publique mais
est-ce que le but est de calmer
l'opinion publique ou de trouver une
solution de plus long terme le on a du
mal à imaginer autre chose qu'une
réponse militaire aujourd'hui quand on a
absolument du mal la population
israélienne la demande et moi je
voudrais réagir très calmement sur deux
choses qui viennent d'être dites
premièrement c'est la première fois
qu'il y a un massacre par des commandos
qui sont préparés de population civile
massacre absolument atroce et donc la
réponse de Benjamin N est évidemment
seul que le peuple israélien souhaite
effectivement on est dans ce cycle que
le proche orient com connaît on nous
attaque on va à Gaza il va y avoir des
civils tués et blessés c'est absolument
terrible et malheureusement c'est ça la
guerre il y a des civils qui sont tués
dans les guerres là où moi j'apporte mon
expérience c'est que j'ai vécu à Gaza
donc je sais très bien par rapport à
certaines personnes qui sont sur ce
plateau ce que ça veut dire Gaza ce
qu'est la population civile Gaza c'est
un territoire où il y a 3 millions de
person
vous avez dans chaque famille à peu près
10 à 11 personnes souvent qui vivent
tout le monde sait ce qui se passe et
c'est d'ailleurs comme ça que le Hamas
manipule aussi la population civile il y
a des combattants du Hamas qui sont
cachés dans la population civile il y a
des enfants dont les grands frères ont
été tués qui ont un désir de vengeance
absolu c'est une situation sans fin ce
qui est terrible dans cette histoire
qu'on commente c'est que régulièrement
il y a une crise régulièrement on entend
les mêmes mot là il y a une escalade de
la terreur qui est en train de se faire
sous nos yeux avec une intensité doublée
par une propagande sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'on n jamais connu ça pose la
question Guillaume mansel de de
l'adhésion on va dire du du peuple
palestinien aux attaques terroristes du
Hamas c'est c'est ce que j'entends
sous-jacente dans dans l'intervention de
faut il faut s'interroger quand même
face à cette attaque qui est malgré tout
d'un style nouveau on avait pas connu ce
genre d'attaque avec des massacres dé
organisé par des commandos multiples
très bien coordonnés sans matériel
sophistiqué mais avec une un mode
d'organisation que je qualifierais de
très sophistiqué moi j'y vois deux
choses la première c'est une préparation
qui a été faite avec des acteurs
extérieurs c'est pas du niveau du Hamas
ce qui s'est passé il y a d'autres
acteurs qui sont venus les convaincre
d'agir comme ça parce que arrivé à
cibler et à faire de on rendez compte on
est au 5e jour des combats l'armée
israélienne n'a toujours pas a repris le
contrôle complet du territoire israélien
c'est son premier rôle avant d'aller
attaquer Gazin son rôle c'est c'est
d'abord de rétablir la sécurité
c'estàdire que tous les terroristes
infiltré ont pas été retrouvé exactement
et pourquoi parce que ils ont utilisé un
modèle qui est assez sophistiqué de
cellules dormantes c'està-dire d'équipes
qui s'infiltrent sur place qui ne sont
pas actives tout de suite qui attendent
que l'armée pense avoir sécurisé le
territoire et qui redevienne active et
du coup on découvre au fur et à mesure
de nouveaux charniers parce qu'en fait
on a du mal à aller partout et à voir ce
qui s'est passé donc c'est c'est juste
pour dire que ce mode là n'est pas à mon
avis à la portée conceptuelle du Hamas
il y a d'autres acteurs extérieur qui
les ont aidé à monter cette affaire et
pourquoi ils les ont monté les aidé à
monter une attaque d'une telle atrocité
parce que c'est insoutenable ce qu'ils
ont fait du côté israélien c'est
forcément avec un but pour moi le but
premier c'est d'obliger l'armée
israélienne à se lancer dans une guerre
il y a une escalade régionale et je dis
juste par mon analyse que à mon avis
vite ça va beaucoup trop vite et surtout
que netaniahou parce que c'est lui qui a
la responsabilité de cette attaque il se
précipite exactement à l'endroit où
l'attend le Hamas et je juste dans une
guerre comme ça l'émotion ne doit pas
empêcher la réflexionou on va y revenir
je vous redonne la parole Aurélien deiso
sur justement la la la réplique la Rost
israélienne là on parle de 2300 cibles
on a bien compris ce que ça provoquait à
Gaza des habitants qui de toute façon
sont sont dans l'incapacité de s'enfuir
c'est c'est ça la réalité de Gaza
aujourd'hui B théoriquement Israël
demande à l'Égypte d'ouvrir sa frontière
même si l'Égypte ouvre sa frontière on
imagine bien que on va pas vider cette
population en quelques jours donc même
si cette population partait de Gaza
aujourd'hui et en plus est-ce que les
Égyptiens ont envie de les accueillir
mais est-ce qu'il a ai la question qui
se pose bien sûr on va y revenir tout à
l'heure sur le corridor humanitaire avec
Mathieu mais est-ce que il y a une
adhésion
populaire au sein de la bande de Gaza
qui peut être aussi provoqué par la
riposte militaire israélienne mais on se
pose là la question vous avez mis ce ce
débat sur le tapis donc allons-y
maintenant est-ce que le Hamas est
soutenu et par quelle part de la
population palestinien les dernières
élections ça fait plus de 15 ans ça va
faire bientôt 20 ans 2006 les dernièr
les premières élections c'est 2006 et le
Hamas était complètement soutenu par
défaut de
l'autorité on n pas eu d'élection depuis
on ne sait pas ce que la population en
pense et dans avec un gouvernement comme
le Hamas en plus enfin un régime qui
gère Gaza comme le Hamas on imagine bien
que l'opposition n'a pas forcément en
plus les moyens de se faire entendre et
si vous alliez interroger même
aujourd'hui des Palestiniens du Hamas je
sais pas si on aurait les moyens de les
faire s'exprimer librement de savoir ce
qu'ils en pensent moi ce que je trouve
très intéressant quand même c'est quand
vous parlez à des gens qui sont à ramala
donc qui dépendent de l'Autorité
palestinienne ils soutiennent
publiquement ce qui s'est passé donc il
y a quand même une unité palestinienne
qui est en train de se faire autour du
ramas je voudrais simplement très
brièvement revenir sur ce que Guillaume
Ansel disait qui me paraît très
intéressant ça a été préparé coordonné
extrêmement bien exécuté avec un mode
opératoire qui d'une certaine manière
est très surprenant de la part du Hamas
il y a beaucoup de gens maintenant qui
analysent précisément sur le terrain ce
qui se passe qui pensent par exemple que
le Djihad islamique était là parce que
lorsqu'on parle de corps décapités
d'exécution de gens qui ont été brûlé
sans encore une fois aller puisque nous
sommes ici à Paris non pas sur le
terrain dans le détail vous vous rendez
compte qu'il y a un mode exécutoire de
vouloir tuer des gens qui ressemble
beaucoup à ce que l'État islamique
faisait et en tout cas et là où
Guillaume a raison c'est que l'opération
a été planifiée organisée orchestrée
exécuté avec des moyens très importants
aen de parce qu'on peut considérer que
c'est presque suicidaire de la part du
Hamas est-ce que ça voudrait dire je
reprends un peu vos arguments l'un
l'autre que avant de se lancer dans une
telle opération il y a eu des gar
garantie donné par des soutiens
internationaux du Ham en disant on sera
derrière vous on va vous aider on va
c'est tout à fait possible c'est tout à
fait possible en effet qu' a eu un
soutien un encouragement un appui
étranger on sait que la question de la
normalisation entre le gouvernement
israélien et certains gouvernements
arabes ne plaisait pas à tout le monde
dans la région l'Iran par exemple
pouvait craindre cette normalisation il
pouvait la refuser montrer qu'il était
en désaccord des acteurs comme le
hzbollah également est-ce que pour
autant le Hamas a pris le risque de
disparaître un certain nombre de chefs
du Hamas ne sont même pas dans la bande
de Gaza ils agissent depuis le Qatar ou
ailleurs et ils peuvent au contraire se
dire que un nouveau bombardement
reconstituerait leur vivier militant
alors on en reparlera de cette question
là mais je voudrais qu'on développe une
autre information celle-là on va la
prendre avec beaucoup de prudence
puisque on on a eu sur le fil de
l'Agence France Presse source armée
israélienne une suspicion je prends les
termes suspicion d'infiltration aérienne
depuis le Liban dans le nord d'Israël
des sirènes d'alertes qui ont retenti
euh Guillaume Ansel je je veux
simplement rester prudent parce que il y
a une source seulement qui dit ça pour
l'instant et une source américaine qui
dit qu'il ne croit pas vraiment à un
risque de contagion votre avis là-dessus
parce que ça rejoint ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur finalement qui est
derrière le Hamas et et quel est le coup
d'après en fait le le le risque
principal maintenant dans la région
c'est l'escalade et si le hbolah par
exemple ouvrait un deuxième front au
nord d'Israël ce serait très compliqué
ce serait très compliqué pour Israël et
ce serait très compliqué pour toute la
région qui pourrait s'embraser sans
compter que jusqu'ici il y a eu peu
d'incidents aussi Jordanie par rapport à
ce qu'on craignait à un moment donc on
voit bien que le risque c'est l'escalade
c'est pour ça que pour moi l'opération
que prépare tsal contre la bande de Gaza
est plus dangereuse que bénéfique
surtout si on considère les otages parce
que c'est pas avec ce genre d'opération
qu'on va récupérer les otages mais cette
comment dire cette alerte sur le fait
qu'il aurait une incursion aérienne et
qui a eu des bombardements pratiquement
depuis 3 jours il y a un ou deux
bombardements ça reste très sporadique
on voit bien que le hzbolah montre qu'il
est présent qu'il pourrait agir mais
n'intervient pas plus et donc ça met
l'armée israélienne en difficulté parce
qu'elle est obligée de mobiliser des
forces importantes au cas où elle sait
que cette fois elle peut pas dire que
elle a pas eu d'alerte mais sans
réellement pouvoir agir tant qu'il y a
pas une attaque avérée ça la met dans
une situation de tension et qui est
inutile à un moment elle aurait besoin
de se concentrer sur ce qui se passe au
sud d'Israël alors on va écouter et
Mathie on va parler du corridor
humanitaire dans une seconde mais je
voudrais vous proposer un premier
témoignage dans dans ce dans ce débat un
habitant du quartier de Carama on est
dans la ville de Gaza après des frappes
israéliennes nocturne sur son
quartier c'est arrivé et c'était comme
une apocalypse ou un tremblement de
terre cela vient de l'Amérique ou
d'Israël pourquoi ont-ils fait cela à
des personnes innocentes ces gens n'ont
rien fait les Israéliens sont venus pour
détruire comme si ces gens ne méritaient
pas de vivre comme s'ils n'étaient pas
des humains gâs sont incroyables il se
croirait en pleine
apocalypse dimanche Matthieu le Premier
ministre israélien a invité les Gazaoui
à fuir concrètement ça veut dire quoi
bah c'est ce qu'on appelle un
avertissement d'un très grand cynisme
partez maintenant où nous allons opérer
puissamment partout a déclaré dimanche
en effet Benjamin netaniaahou dis que
c'est cynique car les Gazaoui ne peuvent
aller nulle part ils n'ont nulle part où
aller et d'ailleurs dès le lendemain le
ministre de la Défense annoncé avoir
ordonné un siège complet pour couper
Gaza du reste du monde d'électricité pas
de nourriture pas de gaz tout est fermé
précisé le ministre de la défense avant
de clamer nous combattons des animaux et
nous agissons en conséquence alors
l'invitation de de à partir de de
benamin netaniao elle était de toute
façon purement rhtorique d'abord parce
que même avant les attentats du Hamas de
samedi ben les entrées et les sorties ne
se faisaient plus qu'au comptegoutûte on
rappelle que sur les SEP points de
passage que comptait la bande de gazar
et 5 ont été progressivement fermé
depuis 2005 et que ne subsistait que le
poste frontière d'erz he côté israélien
et celui de Rafa côté égyptien les deux
sont aujourd'hui fermés parce que il
faut le dire aussi les deux pays Israël
évidemment mais l'Égypte aussi vous le
disiez n'ont aucune envie de les
accueillir comment font les les
habitants de Gaza ben dans les faits
vous disiez 3 millions en Dre 2,3 et
voilà millions de Gazaoui sont donc
condamnés à fuir au sein de ce petit
territoire de 345 365 pardon kilm carré
on le rappelle il fuit pour se mettre à
l'abri et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils
font alors l'ONU a déclaré aujourd'hui
que près de 260 000 personnes avaient
été contraintes de fuir leur domicile je
viens de dire 2,3 million d'habitants
donc 274000 c'est quand même un/ 10 a
été obligé de fuir à l'intérieur de la
bande de Gaza le bureau de coordination
des affaires humanitaires de l'ONU a
fait état de plus de 1000 logements
détruits 500 rendus inhabitables par les
frappes et toujours selon l'ONU près de
175000 déplacés c'est quand même énorme
on retrouv refuge dans les écoles gérées
par le Programme d'aide au réfugiés
palestiniens des Nations Unies d'où
cette idée d'installer un corridor oui
parce qu'une gigantesque crise
humanitaire ce profil rendez compte on a
dit rien de passe à min de la défense
donc rien de passe ni nourriture ni
matériel médical absolument rien donc
l'OMS l'Union européenne par la voix de
ses ministres des Affaires étrangères
hier soir les États-Unis aussi et puis
évidemment toutes les ONG le réclame ce
corridor humanitaire ce serait le seul
moyen de pouvoir acheminer à la fois de
l'aide alimentaire s'il en fallait du
matériel médical surtout et d'évacuer
les populations civiles vers où Ben vers
l'Égypte une demande le problème c'est
que cette demande aujourd'hui reste C
lettre morte parce que aucun commentaire
à Jérusalem comme Auer Aurélien deiso
les les États-Unis l'Union européenne
effectivement réclame ce corridor est-ce
qu'ils peuvent être entendu ou est-ce
que c'est totalement
illusoire c'est très difficile à savoir
he tout dépend des moyens qu'ils vont
mettre en œuvre aussi pour l'avir
c'està-dire est-ce que c'est une demande
qui est faite pour parce qu'il faut
demander quelque chose parce qu'il faut
agir jeen pense en particulier aux
Européens oou est-ce qu'ils ont des
moyens de pression est-ce qu'ils vont
mettre en œuvre ces moyens de pression
par comment est-ce qu'ils vont être
rendu est-ce qu' est qu'ils vont trouver
des relais régionaux est-ce qu'ils vont
trouver des partenaires régionaux pour
mettre en place ce corridor pour
l'instant on est quand même dans la
certitude je veux dire c'est ça paraît
pas impossible mais il faudrait quand
même qu'il développe un peu pour qu'on
puisse savoir qu'est-ce qu'ils attendent
exactement sur veent s'appuer parardon
Inter les États-Unis sont au soutien
d'Israël depuis le début de de de des
attaques terroristes mais est-ce qu'ils
peuvent mettre des conditions à ce
soutien alors il y a une petite
information c'est que le président Biden
a demandé au secrétaire d'État Anthony
blinken de prendre l'avion il va arriver
dans quelques heures euh à TelAviv et il
va sans doute justement parler de ce
corridor humanitaire parce que pour les
Américains c'est prioritaire faire en
sorte qu'il y a un corridor humanitaire
pour cette population civile et pour
éviter une crise humanitaire d'une
ampleur considérable h ycel j'ai j'ai un
petit peu de mal avec cette notion de
corridor humanitaire en général c'est le
truc qu'on invente qu'on sorte son
chapeau quand on ne veut pas condamner
une opération militaire qui n'est pas
soutenable assiéger la bande de Gaza
comme comme au moyen ménage parce que
c'est ça que va faire l'armée
israélienne parce que elle a été
agressée pardon c'est moi qui termine
parce que l'armée israélienne est
horriblement vexé d'avoir perdu la
première phase de la guerre elle a
absolument pas venu vu venir les choses
et surtout elle a été très lente en
réaction par rapport au massacreur qu' a
envoyé Hamas mais du coup aujourd'hui
l'ONU l'a rappelé assiéger une
population civile c'est un crime de
guerre donc je suis juste étonné que les
États-Unis comme la France ne disent pas
non attendez le problème c'est pas le
corridor humanitaire c'est qu'on ne peut
pas accepter qu'il a un siège de la
bande de Gaza que les Israéliens veulent
légitimement détruire le Hamas c'est
normal mais mais par contre ça n'est pas
en détruisant Gaza qu'ontire peuton
faire l'un sans l'autre pardon peut-on
faire l'un sans l'autre c'est ce que
vous disis tout à l'heure mais on peut
pas assimiler les deux sinon c'est c'est
acceptter de martyriser une population
civile pour détruire un organisme
politique à l'intérieur mais pardon mais
là on va vers un massacre de grande
ampleur donc pour moi politiquement
comme juridiquement c'est inacceptable l
votre avis là-dessus sur sur le je reste
sur la question du poids que les alliés
de d'Israël peuvent faire peser
justement pour que cette opération
militaire peut-être reste dans un cadre
je sais pas si c'est possible mais le
plus légal possible moi j'étais à Gaza
au moment de 2014 et j'étais à Gaza en
2002 2003 et 2004 donc je sais
exactement comment vivent les gazaou et
je pense que lorsque vous avez vécu
l'intérieur de Gaza il y a des choses
qui ne peuvent pas s'expliquer
naturellement géopolitique il y a des
gens qui souffrent il y a des gens qui
savent aussi très bien résister au
blocus il y a une infrastructure de
tunnel à Gaza avec des centaines de
kilomètres des labyrinthes qui ont
permis au gazaou d'acheminer des armes
de la nourriture de l'essence lorsqueil
y a eu un blocus est-ce que c'est encore
possible aujourd'hui on ne sait pas on y
est pas mais en tout cas il y a un
labyrinthe qui est fait il y a pas mal
de gens qui pensent que les otages
d'ailleurs ont été mis dans ces tunnels
ce qui va rendre l'opération de secours
des otages extrêmement difficile en tout
cas dans une guerre et c'est horrible à
dire mais c'est la vérité il y a des
blessés et des morts dans les
populations civiles ce qui s'est passé
et encore une fois je suis journaliste
je ne prends parti ni pour l'un ni pour
l'autre il y aura une opération
militaire à Gaza dans une zone qui a été
négligé par la communauté internationale
depuis des années c'est une erreur
collective ce qui est en train de se
passer parce que on s'occupait d'autre
chosees où l'argent n'arrivait pas à qui
c'était destiné et il faut pas
simplement prendre ce conflit par les
massacre qui sont passés samedi en
disant les Israéliens c'est horrible ils
vont aller à Gaza tuer la population
civile c'est beaucoup plus complexe ce
sont des années des décennies de
conflits non résolus et lorsque vous
êtes en Israël il y a toujours une
expression qui revient on achète la paix
pour 3 à 5 ans et on voit après ce qui
se passe et c'est ça l'erreur il y a
personne qui s'est véritablement penché
sur ce ce conflit pour essayer à un
moment donné de résoudre cette situation
à Gaza qui a été dramatique pendant des
années on l'a déjà évoqué longuement sur
ce plateau on peut en dire un gu c'est
notamment l'échec ou l'erreur de
Benjamin netaniaahou alors je pense que
Laurence a tout à fait raison quand elle
dit c'est d'abord un échec collectif
c'est pas c'est pas alors attention ça
n'enlève rien la responsabilité ignoble
des massacres qui ont été commis par le
on l'explique on le légitime surtout pas
mais pour moi c'est d'abord l'échec
d'une politique ultra Sécur ire de
netanahou qui avait promis la sécurité à
Israël et et en fait qui lui apporte sur
un plateau une guerre une guerre
d'autant plus ignoble que finalement
elle va lui permettre de préserver son
pouvoir donc il y a quelque chose de
complètement paradoxal dans cette
situation normalement netaniahù il
devrait être balayé par l'opposition
interne qui l'a créé et finalement c'est
cette guerre qui va peut-être lui
permettre dans un premier temps de
rester au pouvoir ensuite arrivera le
moment des comptes et là ce sera
extrêmement intéressant parce que moi je
tiens de sources israéliennes que la
alerte sur l'attaque du Hamas a été
remontée au gouvernement ce que n'arrive
pas à me dire les services de
renseignement c'est est-ce que elle a
été noyé dans une multitude d'alertes
qui fait que le gouvernement est
légitime de dire on a pas vu celle-ci
plus que les 15 autres par jour ou
est-ce queelle a été écarté parce que en
fait ça ne les désarrangeait pas qui est
cette guerre et ça jusqu'au bout on aura
l'incertitude sur cette question qui est
horrible et donc on va rester évidemment
prudent là-dessus je voudrais qu'on
ouvre un chapitre consacré aux otages
parce que évidemment la question des
notage complique la stratégie militaire
les les familles des personnes qui sont
portées disparu les derniers chiffres il
y a pas de chiffres précis on parle de
150 à 200 otages c'est ces familles
elles prennent lentement conscience que
leurs proches sont sans doute détenus
par le Hamas écoutez cette dentiste elle
vit dans un kibut qui a été ciblé par
les terroristes palestiniens sa mère sa
sœur ses niestes font parti des
otages d'un côté au moins on les a vu
partir vivante mais de l'autre que Dieu
les protège ils les ont pris que leur
font-ils où sont-elles comment les
traitent-ils eux qui ont deux petites
filles l'une de 2 ans et demi l'autre de
4 ans et demi que vont-ils leur faire
là-bas et lentement lentement nous
commençons à comprendre la situation
dans son ensemble à savoir que de très
nombreuses personnes plus de 50
personnes de mon seul kibuts ont été
enlevées Aurélien deiso quelle peut être
la stratégie du Hamas avec avec ses
otages
monnaie d'échange bah pour le moment de
toute façon on imagine mal des
négociations s'entamé alors ou alors au
niveau le plus secret
évidemment le risque évidemment le
risque le plus terrible c'est que le
Hamas immédiatement ou ses différents
alliés utilise les otages pour aller
encore plus loin dans l'horreur par
exemple avec les menaces d'exécution à
chaque
bombardement à plus long terme qu'est-ce
que le Hamas essaie d'obtenir avec ses
otages est-ce qu'il va être prêt à
négocier il faudrait qu'il trouve dans
ce cas des intermédiaires parce que on
imagine mal politiquement ce serait
intenable évidemment une négociation
directe entre Israël et le Hamas est-ce
qu'il y a des acteurs régionaux qui sont
prêts à se mouiller dans une négociation
de ce genre avec tous les risques les
risques humains les risques aussi en
terme d'image qui sont derrière c'est
pas certain non plus vous avez un
certain nombre de pays on peut penser au
Qatar on peut penser à la Turquie on
peut penser même à l'Égypte peut-être
dans certaines circonstances qui pourrai
essayer de jouer ce rôle de médiation
mais encore une fois je pense que tant
que la crise n'est pas à son acmé tant
qu'on est dans cette espèce de
d'explosion de violence tant qu'il n'y a
pas une désescalade pour le moment on
voit mal ce genre de négociation souv
oui s'il y a des négociations elles sont
certainement secrètes Mathieu elles sont
pas elles sont pardon elles sont pas
secrètes les négociations il y a pas ENF
on a le temps de la guerre et et les
négociations en même temps ou mais en
tout cas il y a une demande officielle
qui a été faite à nos confrères de CNN
par bargouti qui est aramala qui est un
responsable de l'Autorité palestinienne
et qui disait voilà ce qu'on veut pour
libérer les a age et il parlait de plus
de 1000 prisonniers politiques
palestiniens de plus il donnait un
chiffre important de gens qui sont
détenus dans les prisons israéliennes et
il disaient c'est ça qu'on veut on se
souvient qu'il y avait un frutorité
palestinienne c'est pas le RAM non mais
il soutenait complètement le ramas et là
il semble qu'il y ait quand même une
unité de l'autorité palestinine avec le
ramas pour ne pas condamner ouvertement
les massacres atroces qui se sont passés
moi je suis frappé quand on entend les
pores-paroles de l'armée israélienne
c'estàd ceux qui sont envoyés sur les
télévisions françaises euh ils disent la
priorité ils le disent de façon assez
directe c'est l'éradication du Hamas
donc la question des otages alors ils le
disent avec des mots pour coup
compliqués mais ils disent c'est pas
notre c'est d'une certaine façon la
priorité c'est l'éradication du Hamas et
la société israélienne va peut-être
devoir accepter que la question des
otages ne soit pas prioritaire donc je
trouve c'est la première fois qu'on
entend ça de la part du pouvoir
israélien et deuxièmement il y a
beaucoup de binationaux dans ces otages
de ce conseil est-ce que ça ça peut
jouer pour le coup est-ce que les gouver
peutêtre que Guillaume hsel peut parler
je vais juste RER les derniers chiffr
qui concern les les Français les
binationaux français en cette fin
d'après-midi on parle désormais de 11
morts et et toujours 188 disparus dont
plusieurs enfants sont les termes qui
ont été employés par la première
ministre cet après-midi au Sénat a dit
plusieurs enfants parmi les otages
est-ce que le la la présence de
bationaux gel ça change la donne ou pas
al ça change la donne au sens que les
opinions publques nationales se sentent
directement impliqué à partir du moment
il y a des Français qui sont menacés en
Israël là c'est c'est pas seulement une
communauté c'est toute la France qui dit
mais attendez c'est pas possible c'est
nos citoyens pourquoi est-ce qu'il ser
ce qui est très compliqué dans ce genre
de situation c'est que en fait Israël
n'a pas repris le contrôle complet de
son territoire et donc à ce stade ce
sont plutôt des disparus c'estàd qu'on
n'est pas sûr qu'il soit a Tage on ne
sait pas s'ils sont au fond un charnier
ou s'ils ont été embarqués par le Hamas
et s'ils ont été embarqués dans le Hamas
par le Hamas pardon est-ce qu'ils sont h
Tage ou est-ce qu'ils sont morts de
leurs blessures ou des mauvais
traitements donc il y a une incertitude
très forte sur le sujet qui fait que on
ne peut que s'interroger sur ce que va
faire le Hamas avec à mon avis ce seront
malheureusement s'il y a encore des
otages s'il y a encore réellement des
otages ce seront les premières victimes
du début de l'opération militaire et
donc ça Hal va essayer de mettre
complètement de côté le sujet pour ne
pas être gêné dans son attaque et c'est
là où à mon avis la de toute façon aura
fait ses premières victimes du côté
israélienne ce seront celles-ci Laurent
sa il faut peut-être rappeler un fait
historique qui concerne Benyamine
netanahou son son frère c'est ça est
mort dans une opération il y a une
opération qui a eu lieu qui était enanda
c'est l'opération an TB ça s'est passé
dans les années 70 et c'est un avion
d'airfance qui a été pris par des
terroristes palestinien avec plus d'une
centaine de passagers qui ont été
détenus pendant des jours et qui ont été
l'avion a été transporté en Ouganda et à
ce moment-là les Israéliens ont décidé
de faire un raid pour libérer les otages
et la personne qui dirigeait le raid
était le frère de Benjamin netaniaahou
il a été tué lors de ce raid et lorsque
vous parlez à Benjamin netaniaou il vous
dit toujours qu'il a été extrêmement
marqué par ce frère qui est mort en
libérant les otages et ça a imprégné
politiquement Benjamin netaniaahou qui a
grandi avec ce frère mort pour libérer
des otages français des otages
israéliens il y a eu plusieurs morts les
terroristes palestiniens il
appartenaient à un commando Septembre
noir ont été tués mais dans l'histoire
d'Israël antb c'est quelque chose de
très emblématique c'est-à-dire que le
commandau des forces spéciales dirigé
par le frère de netanahou savait qu'il y
avait un risque ils y ont été ils ont
libéré les otages le frère de netanahou
a été tué encore une fois ça ça aura une
influence sur les décisions à venir de
Benjamin netaniaou je voudrais
simplement dire vous avez posé tout à
l'heure la question quelle est la
stratégie de ramass sur les otages ils
ont répondu ils ont fait un communiqué à
chaque bombardement on tuera chaque
bombardement sans sommation à chaque
bombardement sans sommation sur Gaza on
tuera en direct un otage donc la
propagande de la terreur a été
clairement affichée par has et les
Israéliens ont répondu aussi en disant
attention nous vous demandons de ne pas
diffuser les images qui vont apparaître
des otages détenus des otages exécutés
des otages torturés donc ils ont quand
même des informations aussi que des
otages restent toujours vivant à l'heure
actuelle guaum en TB c'est c'est un très
bon exemple et en même temps c'est un
contre exemple en TB c'est le prototype
d'opération assez classique de on va
chercher des otages mais qui sont
détenus sur un lieu parfaitement
déterminé qui est à la portée d'une
opération en plus à l'époque c'est un
aéroport en Uganda donc la complexité
c'est d'arriver à débarquer par surprise
c'est exactement le contraire band gaz
que la bande de Gaza c'est un camp de
prisonnier à ciel ouvert surpeuplé et
dans lequel on va rentrer à l'intérieur
pour aller chercher 50 Otages alors que
en réalité c'est un camp sur plusieurs
étages puisqu'il y a des souterrains sur
plusieurs étage mais c'est condamné à
mort dès le départ les aages par interom
est-ce que c'est d'abord une opération
militaire terrestre qui va se qui qui se
prépare et qui se profile à l'horizon et
puis dans ce cadre- làà s'il y a la
possibilité de sauver quelqu des otages
on en sauvera ça rejoint ce que disait
Mathieu sur la communication officielle
de l'armée israélienne qui fait pas du
sort des otages la priorité c'est c'est
clairement euh la stratégie qui en tout
cas est affichée par tal parce que pour
récupérer les otages moi j'ai participé
à des opérations de libération d'otage
on on si on fait ce que fait sal
actuellement c'està dire bombarder
largement se mettre autour assiéger et
rentrer en force les otages sont morts
par nature je ve dire il il y a pas
d'autres destination pour les otages
donc ça n'est pas leur stratégie
actuelle de libérer les otages Laurence
l'a rappelé c'est de dire le Hamas va
s'en servir pour essayer de ralentir
l'offensive mais euh l'armée israélienne
a manifestement pour ordre d'envahir
Gaza très vite ah très vite euh les
Américains vont aider sur la tentative
de libération des otages parce qu'on a
appris aujourd'hui que la team six qui
est cette unité d'élite des forces
spéciales américaines qui a participé au
raid contre Osama Ben Laden vient
d'arriver en Israël pour apporter toute
son aide sur place euh à l'armée
israélienne pour essayer d'aller libérer
les otages il y a des otages américains
et pour les les Américains ça va être
très important aussi d'essayer de sortir
leur ressortissant vivant évidemment
vous parliez tout à l'heure de des des
narratifes des images et et du fait que
chaque camp entre guillemetsin soit
abreuvé de ses propres images on va
parler des informations tout de suite
grâce à Marion Vigreux c'est un des
éléments importants de ce de ce conflit
on pourrait dire la guerre
informationnelle bonsoir Marion avec un
déferlement et finalement on doit tous
collectivement être particulièrement
prudent de de fausses informations de
d'images trafiqué oui des images et des
vidéos parfois choquantes qui ont été
relayées sur Facebook Twitter et TikTok
certaines sont malheureusement bien
réelles d'autres pas du tout et depuis
le début du conflit plusieurs
vérificateurs s'attachent donc à repérer
les manipulations c'est le cas des
décodeurs du journal Le Monde parmi les
images identifiées on va en voir
quelques-unes ensemble il y a tout
d'abord cette capture d'écran d'une
vidéo de cinq enfants enfermé dans une
cage et présenté comme des otages
israéliens les vérificateurs ont daté
son apparition en ligne du 5 octobre
soit 2 jours avant l'attaque du Hamas
elle n'a donc rien à voir avec les
événements de ce weekend au trintox la
photo d'un homme arrêté par le Hamas il
est présenté comme un général israélien
et ce cliché vient illustrer pour ceux
qui la diffusent la faillite de l'armée
israélienne le S britannique le
télégraphe l'a relayé mais après
vérification il s'avère que ce ne sont
pas les mêmes personnes et le général en
question n'a pas été fait prisonnier
enfin il y a aussi cette photo d'un
immeuble à sevrance C en scène Saint- n
où plusieurs drapeaux palestiniens
apparaissent aux fenêtres avec en
légende la banlieu soutient le Hamas
l'image a été partagé par plusieurs
comptes proches de l'extrême Drom mais
aussi par une ancienne ministre des
affaires européennes de de Jacques
Chirac Noël Lenoir si cette photo a bien
été prise à Sevran elle n'est pas liée
aux événements récents mais daterait
donc du printemps 2021 après un nouvel
affrontement entre le Hamas et Israël
dans la bande de Gaza ces vidéos
manipulées elles ont été largement fusé
sur le réseau social x l'ancien Twitter
et c'est notamment dû à la nouvelle
politique d'é musk oui il est accusé de
laxisme de laisser sa plateforme
répandre des contenus illégaux sans
aucune régulation alors comment cela
s'explique écoutez à ce sujet le
journaliste Thomas Huchon il est
spécialiste des enfox et des théories
complotistes il y a beaucoup moins de
modérateurs qu'auparavant et avant musk
on savait qu'il y avait 2000 modérateurs
sur la planète au total euh si et déjà à
l'époque ça ne suffisait pas donc il
faut bien se rendre compte que là on est
dans une situation où où Twitter ne se
donne plus du tout les moyens en interne
de lutter contre la désinformation le
deuxième élément c'est que tous les
complotistes les personnalités d'extrême
droite ceux qui soutenaient parfois le
terrorisme qui soutenait des des des
propos antisémites les choses les plus
horribles qu'on voyait circuler sur
cette plateforme et ben ils sont des
milliers qui qui étaient bannis de
Twitter à avoir pu retourner sur la
plateforme grâce à Elon Musk qui a
décidé de leur refaire une place le
problème c'est pas tant qu'ils ont pu
revenir sur la plateforme et que ils ont
pu en plus bénéficier d'une nouvelle
fonctionnalité he la certification
payante et donc ces gens qui sont des
désinformateurs professionnels
bénéficient d'une fonctionnalité de la
plateforme Twitter qui donne plus
d'audience à leur contenu qu'aux autres
et les autres ce sont notamment les
journalistes qui ont pour certains
refusé de payer pour une certification
de compte et dont les contenus ont donc
perdu en visibilité et en conséquence la
Commission européenne rappelle à l'ordre
Elon Musk oui c'est d'ailleurs l'une des
seules institutions représentatif des
citoyens a tenté de réguler les gafas
Thierry Breton le commissaire au
numérique a donc adressé une lettre à
Elon Musk hier lui rappelant ses
obligation en matière de modération de
contenu il lui donne 24 heures pour
appliquer la loi européenne dans le cas
contraire des sanctions pourrai lui être
imposé principalement financière mais
pour le journaliste Thomas Huchon il
faut aller plus loin avec ces
plateformes écoutez
on devrait fermer Twitter après ce qu'
s'est passé ce weekend au moins le temps
qu'il respecte nos lois et qu'il
respecte le fait qu'ils sont devenus des
médias qui le veuent ou non ils
éditorialisent le contenu ils gagnent de
l'argent en nous présentant ce contenu
ils sont donc des médias et comme vous
comme d'autres journalistes ils doivent
être responsables de ce qu'il diffusent
on ne pourra pas s'en sortir autrement
et pour en savoir davantage sur ce sujet
je vous invite à consulter également
l'article de Guillaume Jacco sur notre
site internet publ xena.fr merci
beaucoup rien deniso fermé Twitter enfin
x ça semble totalement illusoire
évidemment aujourd'hui mais c'est c'est
vrai que on a on a tous pas mal
d'expérience sur ce plateau des la
guerre et fait rarement bon ménage avec
avec l'information et la vérification
c'est encore pire aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous diriez
ça l'impression que j'ai moi quand je
parle avec les gens que je connais
également alors je parle avec des gens
en Turquie en Israël dans le monde arabe
et cetera c'est que que au-delà des
plateformes elles-mêm de ce qu'elle
transmettent et cetera il y a aussi tout
simplement le fait que lorsque vous êtes
dans une situation polarisée une
situation de guerre les gens aiment à se
créer en fait leur narratif les gens
aiment à chercher à regarder ce qui va
aller dans leur sens donc je me pose
toujours la question il faut l' avoir en
tête par N interrompre pour pour
comprendre comment on parlait des pays
qui pourraient éventuellement intervenir
ou pas intervenir ce on parlera plus
longuement dans la seconde partie de des
accords d'Abraham et des voilà de de ce
procè processus de normalisation qui
était en cours avec pas mal de pays
arabes et qui est sans doute tombé à
l'eau pour un certain temps mais il faut
intégrer ces
informations nourr sur les réseaux
sociaux dans les pays en question pour
comprendre la réaction diplomatique
c'est ça oui parce que il faut
comprendre les opinions publiques
aujourd'hui on a les opinions publiques
et c'est peut-être une des erreurs qui
commis par exemple par un certain nombre
d'États arabes qui ont pensé en fait que
ils pouvait se payer le luxe aujourd'hui
ben d'une réconciliation avec Israël
sans prendre en compte les a opinion
publique et ces opinions publiques elles
sont abreuvées aujourd'hui non plus par
des médias gouvernementaux mais
justement par ces nouvelles plateformes
qui sont complètement
incontrôlables ça rend les choses très
dangereuses parce qu'on a des opinions
publiques selon les pays selon les
sociétés qui se créent des narratifs
complètement différents et au bout d'un
moment ben les gouvernants sont obligés
de suivre et ça crée des risques
géopolitiques énormes
gu j'ai une expérience d'ancien officier
mais je suis aussi le directeur de la
communication d'une très grosse
organisation et je suis frappé de voir
comme à chaque guerre c'est d'abord une
guerre de l'information qui pr a la
guerre opérationnelle celle pour
laquelle en général on a très peu
d'information plutôt ce qui est
important n'est pas vu puis par contre
l'information prime comme l'a très bien
noté Aurélien or dans ce cette escalade
qui maintenant dure depuis 5 jours il y
a un relatif silence qui est très
étonnant c'est celui de la Russie de
Poutine on voit que Poutine qui est
hyper actif et qui a annoncé la
composition d'un ordre mondial nouveau à
une attitude sur ce confit qui est tout
à fait tonnante comme sil se tenait un
peu à l'écart mais que par contre sur
les réseaux sociaux ces réseaux sont
hyper actifs on voit bien que Twitter
est devenu une organisation de diffusion
en masse de fausses nouvelles et de
tension et donc je pense qu'on devrait
avoir une attention redoublé sur ce qui
se passe sur Twitter et ce qui se passe
aussi du côté de la Russie Laurence sa
c'est aussi un enjeu d'ailleurs pour
pour Israël parce que on a on a montré
un témoignage de de Gaza
on va avoir des images de des
conséquences des bombardements qui sont
nombreux depuis depuis samedi il va
falloir maîtriser aussi cette
communication là oui alors ayant vécu
beaucoup aux États-Unis et couvert de
nombreuses campagnes présidentielles moi
je sais qu'un président américain peut
être élu grâce à Twitter grâce à X et
donc je suis très frappé de voir que on
ne pourra pas aller en arrière X est
devenu un élément de communication
politique un élément de communication
médiatique un élément de communication
d'entreprise
h est la personne sait mais ça existe
soit on arrête tous d'utiliser X à ce
moment-là on fait pas de campagne
politique on fait pas de communiqué sur
X on ne se met pas dans sa vidéo
visitant un bâtiment dans une crise pour
faire sa petite phrase avec des experts
en communication qui font le bon tweet
soit on arrête tous soit effectivement
il y a une régulation il y a aussi une
différence culturelle par rapport à ce
qui se passe et Thierry Breton c'est
très intéressant qu'il s'adresse
directement à Elon Musk qui d'ailleurs
lui a répondu en français merci je vais
faire attention et cetera euh bon on
souhaite bonne chance on sou bonne
chance à Thierry Breton mais on espère
qu'éon musk le fera ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que aux États-Unis le
débat sur Twitter c'est au nom du
premier amendement de la Constitution
américaine et d'avoir la liberté de
s'exprimer et de pouvoir tout dire qui
est une liberté fondamentale revendiqué
désormais par l'extrême droite et par
les trumpistes et donc le débat il est
extrêmement complexe mais en tout cas en
2023 et en 2024 au moment où il y aura
tant d'élections si importantes Twitter
contrat et dans cette guerre
malheureusement et bien x compte merci à
tous c'est la la fin de ce débat merci à
tous d'y avoir participer je vous dis à
bientôt sur sur Public Sénat